we do it because there is a need there
is a real need that kim has been known
for a year ghislaine renault
founder of a foundation that has existed
for a few years in
quebec i light a star on an agreement with
the university hospital center of
Quebec City is almost 100% of the
parents accept the offer of his service
because you are you arrive at the house
that the empty Hebrew will tell you that you
realize rest then all your entourage
around you well they can not
know finally  they just heard
about then the photo ba is the godfather
is of the entourage with the
siblings to come to see that this child
must exist because that is what for
the parents it is and avic it is a  mourning
was everywhere from 18 weeks to 39
weeks it's in putanges cancon a
call we move we take the pictures
when it started first time it's
still it's very open it's here
I'm even stress m  with the complexion
you say to yourself when I have a trav  all to do
I have to do this job for the
sponsors she offers a
photography service done by volunteers who
have received training to do
their delicate work
it's about taking before and
after photos so that's what  that I can't see far
in thought I know that for the
parents it's extremely difficult
except that me when I when Jean in the
room I go gently with respect let's
hear by a tale is there for them
that we're going to take the pictures  who need
the complexion who need us to be water
we try to do it quickly
because the parents are a bit in a
state of shock are in their bubble
so we do as much as possible then
after that we can we  can withdraw from
the room we will even see a photo again by
a hospital leaving ring
the foundation i light a star also did
a photo and video editing service
we poles when the rats not by
one are retouched  because of  times the
little baby the skin is damaged or when
you were 18 to 24 22 weeks it is
more red and where sedan for the parent
is ok are able to watch
the baby pass who have seen but to show it
to those around the family  sometimes
it's difficult and people who have
difficulty seeing them
so when we give the photos to the
parents the photos are other affected
are in black and white but with them
as we are a photo which can
there are many who go  put
in a small quarter in the house they
will be able to present them to the family
and the entourage by the way it's easier
to watch we also now offer in
Quebec more and more we see
support services for parents
who  are experiencing perinatal bereavement
at the Portrait d'Eclairs foundation in
drummondville, quebec, we have been supporting
parents since 2015 in this kind
of bereavement
durenque and catane and olemps I hope
that our foundation, which is rather
American, does not  could not find in our
region in quebec
so we have like saint martin gendron
and co-founder of the portrait foundation
and only one is contacted by a little
earlier to ask them according to that
keith harris field was not used in
hospitals the option  if we want in agreement
with them, he offers a service to
parents and the testing grounds if we
first decide on the 60-year-old air service and
that his part very quickly in hope at
the hospital for routine checks and
the  doctors and then after a few
orders where there is information that
must resume sad and difficult
to study by voting to terminate their
pregnancy so without preparation because it
does not really happen speaking
with others leave the hospital
it's a bit  a bo ao kavala
having nothing left at all the blade to imagine
and sing very little he is coming home
pic de bdm tube baby nothing of the firebrands
to have to know that they will be
receiving photos soon dollars and the  ibis of
the Bernanos parties  was going to prove much comfort
at three rivers halfway between
montreal and quebec change and catherine
archambault participated last fall
in a flight of doves
he was part of the sixth
ceremony organized by another
organization in quebec the feast of angels
[Music  ]
it's just the worst pain you ca
n't have
i think the emotional pain
was worse than the physical pain which
is the meeting i carry you on the said
well done it could have
especially for isn't then to  my
great astonishment it feels good
to me I had time to discuss it
we see a report from radio canada
international